the founder of pro football talk and he
kicks everything off on nbc sports on
peacock every single day on pft live his
book is available where all books are
acquired it came out last month
playmakers mike florio back here on the
show how you doing mike rich i'm doing
great pal fun fact about john harbaugh
he is 59 years old
chuck noll was 59 when he retired from
the steelers never to be heard from
again in the nfl it's amazing how 30
years has changed the overall fitness
capacity and willingness of these guys
to keep going because i think harbaugh's
going for another 20 years me too um
he's so terrific with the media he's
terrific at the job and at one point i
even pointed out to him you know um he's
he's smart man and i didn't point out to
him saying boy you're a smart guy but
the way i brought it up is like he's the
guy who
you know in the middle of the season's
like okay joe's not working out anymore
we're going to go with lamar and we're
going to change our entire damn playbook
and we are going to be all in on the guy
we're not going to fit
you know uh him into what we like to do
we're just going to do what he likes to
do and go for it
and um
you don't see that very often you know
you don't understand that's the best
kind of coaching you take the players
that you have and you do
what they do well
you don't do the things they don't do
well
and that's how you maximize your team
and you know it's going to change all
the time especially in today's nfl where
your roster is going to change
dramatically you're going to have to
change some of your approaches based
upon who your players are every single
year
he was and and again he volunteered he
did not like the new overtime rule and
wanted the ravens to vote against it and
they didn't
um he doesn't like it um and what did he
like about it uh he because i brought up
the fact that the the he cuz he doesn't
think it's gonna change anything
you know that um
you know that he he thinks most people
are gonna take the ball first anyway
because even if both teams score the
same number of points um and over time
continues you want to have a second
possession
and you want to have the the first
possession
of sudden death
um i pointed out that what you know the
benefits of getting it second is
you would go for it fourth down uh an
eight from your own 20 because you know
you have to as opposed to the team that
gets it first that's a distinct
advantage that's exactly why i don't
like it that's why i wanted to vote
against it it's easy he just thought
like how how long are you going to keep
extending overtime is basically what his
point was well but the reality is each
team gets a possession and then it goes
to sudden death and i think that when
you consider how things would have gone
in that chief's bills game where it had
gotten to the point where it was worse
than even the most high-powered video
game the offense is just up and down the
field the number of points that they
scored in the final five minutes of the
game
whoever got the ball first in overtime
was going to score a touchdown and
whoever got the ball second and overtime
was going to score a touchdown and what
would be fascinating is if the team that
scores first kicks
the single extra point
and then the team that scores second has
to decide do we go for two here
and pin the season
on converting this play or do we kick
the extra point assume you make it
because it's not as automatic as it used
to be and then allow it to become sudden
death so i just think it adds layers and
levels of intrigue and it makes it more
fair it was too much in my opinion
hinging on the outcome of a coin toss
and i think some teams will
choose to kick off and i think that we
will see
a team maybe consider rolling the dice
with a surprise on sidekick if they know
that the other team is going to score a
touchdown anyway on that opening drive
and then we get a chance to match it
we're going to
run the numbers and it's a 15 chance now
to recover an onside kick when they know
it's coming if you pull off a great
surprise your chance of recovering the
onside kick is a lot higher than that i
think we're going to see those
strategies possibly play out at some
point now the other side of it too
now that they've changed this rule we're
not going to have an overtime game in
the postseason for like 15 years that's
right but
so and there aren't going to be many of
these that happen so it's going to take
a decade probably to get enough data
points to see how it all plays out but
i'm fascinated by all the different
strategies that now come into play and i
like the idea that each team is going to
get a crack at getting the ball well i
mean i asked harbaugh exactly the
question that you wrote your post about
this morning that i saw about onside
kicking to get the ball first and go
with an onside kick certainly if you
know you have most you know uh you have
a second possession in your back pocket
a possession that you're going to have
in your back pocket and he said
essentially yeah he used a 10 chance of
getting one correct
um and he's like uh if you think that
like say he used the example the mahomes
josh allen game he goes if you think
that you don't have really much of a
chance to stop the other team because
they're just on such a roll offensively
and you think it's 100 chance your
opponent's going to score why not take
that 10 chance that you get the ball
back it's 90 chance that you lose is
better than 100 chance you lose and he
that's exactly what he said and i really
do think it's higher than 10 because
we wrote something
a few weeks ago about the usfl using the
fourth and 13 alternative to the onside
kick and the adjustment that the nfl
made last year to the formation
for the kickoff
aimed at increasing the percent recovery
the onside kick it actually did move the
percentage from four to fifteen and
that's when you know it's coming
so i really do think you get a better
than 15 chance if you don't know it's
coming if you execute it well maybe if
you see something on film about the way
the guys drop back on the kickoff you
get somebody who may be
half
you know not paying attention at the
time there's you know it's the sean
payton thing from super bowl 44
if somebody unfurls that at the right
moment
it's then you get the ball now you gotta
do is go kick a field goal and you win
mike florio pft live host author of
playmakers uh right here on the rich
eisen show uh simple question what's up
with debo what's happening there
well
when you strip everything related to
your team
from your social media page at a time
when every other receiver that is
eligible for a contract is getting a
contract other than deco metcalf and aj
brown but there's at least some rumbling
that metcalf is going to get paid by
somebody and the titans want to keep
brown this debo samuel contract
situation has been so overlooked it
rarely gets mentioned and this is a guy
who's a combination receiver and running
back and it makes it even more urgent in
my view for him to get his financial
reward he's got a greater physical risk
every time he plays because of the way
they now use him and he's going to have
a shorter career quite possibly if they
continue to use him like a running back
so now is the time for him to take a
stand now is the time for him to try to
get paid and they're carrying around 25
million dollars in cap space for jimmy
garoppolo as they wait to decide what to
do with him if they would just move on
from garoppolo they'd have more than
enough cap space to get debo samuel and
nick bosta taken care of i mean they got
a problem with those two guys bose is
going to want 30 million a year debo is
going to want 27.28 million a year and
both guys deserve it this is one of the
byproducts of having great players they
deserve to get paid and as we see the
receiver market mushroom at the top
it's just a matter of time before debo
gets his and if i were him i'm not doing
anything i'm not setting foot on a field
anywhere until i get my contract now
maybe we'll see him hold in like tj watt
did last year show up be at meetings
work out but just not put himself at
risk of any kind
until he gets paid and obviously it
worked for tj watt and for the steelers
he he showed no ill effects
of not being involved in training camp
for the preseason he went on to have a
defensive player of the year type effort
so
garoppolo getting shoulder surgery and
potentially
removing his chest piece from the
craziest ass chessboard in the history
of the nfl march 2022
has a ripple effect with two guys who
want to get paid and that may be leading
to whatever is going on to take
photographs off of devo's social media
is that essentially the dots being
connected here that
may very well have something to do with
it the 49ers currently have less than 2
million in cap space now look if you
want to create cap space it isn't all
that hard to do it you can take other
contracts you can move money around you
can kick the can into future years
but when you've got an easy 25 million
then you can instantly clear if you move
on from jimmy g and i don't know whether
or not they're just
slow playing this because they think
there's going to be a teddy bridgewater
catastrophic knee injury that all of a
sudden creates a market for jimmy g when
one isn't there he's got 25 million plus
due he's got one year on his contract i
don't know who's going to give up
anything of value for him without a
restructured or extended contract and
he's got no incentive to do it so yeah
the moment they move on from jimmy g
they got a lot more cap space available
for these guys they got to keep and i
can't help but wonder rich at some level
whether there are people in the 49ers
organization who just may be concerned
trey lance isn't ready and i hear those
whispers from time to time not nearly
enough to make a big deal about it but
you can have a split of opinion in the
organization as to whether or not lance
needs another year on the bench and then
it's about spending the 25 million not
just keeping it on the books until labor
day weekend but keeping it all the way
through the season and giving jimmy g
one more year while trey lance continues
to get ready well but not that not a
double
you got to pay your two of your top
players i mean they got to get paid you
got you got a problem i mean like i
don't do that you got a problem last
year it was fine i mean lance was just a
rookie and garoppolo you could keep both
and garoppolo was the guy to get ready
and they damn near made the super bowl
but if these guys got to get paid you
know
the concept and and shanahan was very
open about it at the owners meeting if
it's entirely possible that they could
keep them i just don't know if that's
feasible this time around what are you
hearing about baker mayfield that's been
very quiet
i think it's going to stay quite until
after the draft rich because that is the
next big data point in all of this as we
see
who gets quarterbacks in round one or
round two and if you have a team out
there like the falcons that presumably
is thinking about someone other than
marcus mariota or the panthers thinking
about someone other than sam darnold if
they don't get the guy they want does
that become
someone who would then be interested in
baker mayfield right now it's only the
seahawks and who knows maybe they'll end
up drafting somebody in round one or
round two to supplant drew lock but
there just isn't a lot of buzz right now
and again mayfield holds the cards
neither mayfield nor garoppolo have no
trade clauses but when it comes to a
starting quarterback that no trade
clause is overrated because
if i'm interested in a guy to come in
and be my starter to be the face of my
team the most important player there the
guy who shows up early stays late does
all the things that we need him to do to
lead his teammates he doesn't want to be
there
i don't think i'm making that trade
so all mayfield has to do is kind of dig
in his heels he's getting 18.8 million
no matter what this year his contract is
fully guaranteed as his fifth year
option
and
you just wait
and the browns are in a better position
than the 49ers to squat on that 18
million dollars and let it play out but
i know the teddy bridgewater thing
happened six years ago but that is a
very very unlikely outcome that was such
of a fluke injury
you know quarterbacks are insulated from
contact the rules favor them during the
games they have the red jerseys on at
practice it was just a non-contact knee
blew out for teddy bridgewater so you
know i i i just think that at some point
you got to move on and i wonder there
was supposed to be a podcast that drops
this week with
baker mayfield it would have been his
first public comments since his goodbye
social media message to cleveland i just
wonder if he's going to play along with
the browns you know is he going to
insist on showing up being part of
practice let me in let me be here i'm
part of the team and will they want that
distraction if he decides to be very
aggressive it's all to be determined the
iron with all the irony that if he he's
like deshawn watson i'm gone i'm not
showing up i'm done you know you you you
know i refuse to go and um
or i refuse to come here and or or the
other way around it would be really
really wild i got um mike florio here on
the rich eisen show last one for you and
i want to spend a few minutes on this uh
the old bermuda triangle off the coast
of of uh florida uh looks like we've got
one inside the state of florida that you
keep posting about and it's really just
a fascinating story of this
non-playing season you know tying into
what was in the flores uh suit about you
know um tom brady essentially even
though he was not named showing up you
know what a boat you know or yacht or
whatever the hell it was for steven ross
aryan's
saying you know he's retiring because he
just wanted to pass the torch even
though brady's coming back
and brady's role with the dolphins
potentially and what it might have meant
before he unretired and anyone retires
and then aryans goes and it's not
because brady forced it
what is your two cents on whatever the
hell is going on
with these three bermuda triangle data
points well for me
and this always makes buccaneers fans
and dolphins fans very happy when i say
this but
brady was going to miami
and sean payton was going to miami
and that was the plan
and brady was going to be introduced as
a minority owner of the dolphins as soon
as super bowl week he retired tuesday
february 1.
hours later brian flores drops his
lawsuit which includes
the allegation that he was pressured to
meet with a high-profile quarterback who
was under contract with another team he
doesn't mention who it was it was brady
that was in 2020 when brady was about to
become a free agent after his time with
the patriots ended that lawsuit
short-circuited what the dolphins were
going to do and it was going to be brady
introduced as a minority owner pursuit
of sean payton and they acknowledged
they called the saints about peyton and
they were told by former dolphins gm
jeff ireland who's now assistant gm with
the saints don't waste your time i think
there was more to it than that the
dolphins admit that they considered
making tom brady a minority owner but i
think it was going to be minority owner
here comes peyton and at some point in
the spring bradyon retires and goes to
the dolphins and i say all that now
because we need to keep an eye on the
possibility of brady going to the
dolphins next year because he'll be a
free agent
there's a no tag clause in his contract
with the buccaneers unless they extend
his contract they cannot keep him from
going wherever he wants to go so
look i i think that there's a lot of
smoke there which means there are at
least flickers of flame and i look at it
i can consider this example rich yeah
last year drew brees retires okay let's
say drew brees retired for 40 days
came back after his retirement ends 17
days later sean payton quits
what would drew brees have said
i think he would have said what the hell
man
i'm back and you're leaving there was
none of that vibe with tom brady wasn't
that striking to you there wasn't even a
flinch there wasn't even a batting of an
eye that bruce arians is out 17 days
after tom brady came back and to me that
that said it all
yeah i i i hear you there
and
in some ways it does not make sense that
that aryans would just say you know
uh i i i don't want to stick around here
anymore even though brady is back like
there's there's pieces that don't fit
but how would brady have been able to
unretire and go to miami wouldn't he
have still wouldn't there have been
compensation go to tampa that would be
required to make that work they would
have to compensate the saints to get
peyton they would have to compensate
the buccaneers to get brady but the
wheels were all moving in that direction
and
i don't know whether or not the
buccaneers would have drawn a line in
the sand if it came down to it
i know bruce erin's kind of flippantly
said at the combine they would want five
first-round picks but
i know that the buccaneers were
concerned about miami i know the
buccaneers were concerned about san
francisco
and even though no one's going to admit
it they've crafted this narrative that
can allow bruce aryans to walk out the
door with his head held high and not
feel like he's getting pushed and that's
fine
but
the timeline is too weird the reaction
by brady
is too positive
and what do you mean what do you mean
it's too positive because
his head coach is out he's he's back i
think if he had retired from the
patriots and he comes back and 17 days
later bill belichick quits there's at
least going to be oh what the hell man
there's at least going to be something
it was all just like yeah this is
exactly what we expected and rich i say
that because yes and i may have told you
this before i know i've said it on pft
live i was told within two hours after
tom brady unretired the next shoe to
fall is aryans will be out
and it happened 17 days
[Laughter]
i was told that by someone i trust and i
wasn't able to nail it down and report
it but we hinted at it the next morning
on pft live i said i'll be surprised if
both brady and aryans are with the
buccaneers week one and 16 days after
that is when it happened so that's why
i'm very skeptical because
i i mean people i trust were telling me
that it was coming and other people i
trust were telling me that this miami
thing was very very real and i and i
heard that aaron's and and brady you
know had gears grinding and that you
know uh when it all comes down to it
brady didn't
really uh prefer aaron's approach
sometimes not just about the way he was
talking but just the way he would run
run things there undisciplined that's
one way to retire showing up
barnstorming in messing up the work that
he left which were doing think about
that any workplace if the boss has
checked out
half or most of the time and then shows
up late in the week after you've been
busting your ass all week to try to get
things in order right it starts changing
things it's going to irritate you
afterwards well but but i heard that
brady could have still lived with it
though when it all comes down to it well
right you know maybe they maybe they
they i don't you know they just ignore
him in 2020 too i i don't know what they
would have done but
i i it's
it's one hell of a coincidence
and and maybe there are coincidences
maybe there aren't but this is one we've
never seen before where one of the great
all-time players
retires for 40 days comes back and 17
days later his head coaches out and
there's no reason for the head coach to
walk away other than the narrative that
they crafted which is a very positive
uplifting idea that he wants to hand
with ton to todd bowles under
circumstances where he has a chance to
succeed that's great i support that but
i also
am
not willing to
believe that it's exactly the way it
went down and that's you know
that's i know that's not a popular take
with buccaneers fans and bruce arians
but that's what i believe well i hear i
thought that uh my guy chris brockman's
day was made just because tiger woods
his favorite uh non-new england athlete
is performing at the masters but you
just made his day because he's been he's
been he's been he's the same thing
you've been well you've been you've been
you've been you've been all over this
whole
narrative
that's what i said
it doesn't pass the smell test yeah
mike have a great weekend thanks again
man right back at you that's mike floria
everybody go get his book playmakers
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here